[Music]
in our previous video we studied what
mathematical statements are but do we
know how they are denoted yes
mathematical statements are generally
denoted using lowercase letters like P Q
R and so on so it can also be written as
this pretty simple isn't it now that
we've understood mathematical statements
completely let's try and understand the
negation of a statement okay so what
does the word negation tell you yes it's
the negative of something so for example
if I say the earth is round in shape
then what will be the negation of this
statement yes the negation would be the
earth is not round in shape now consider
this example what will be the negation
of this statement will it be Jordan is
short
not really remember that negation is
just the negative of a statement that is
we just deny the statement but we don't
say the opposite of that statement so
the correct answer would be Jordan is
not tall okay let's take one more
example for clarity consider this
statement what will be the negation of
this statement mango is a fruit no that
is incorrect here too we should not
correct the statement we just deny it so
the correct answer would be mango is not
a vegetable so this brings us to the
definition of negation the negation of a
statement is nothing but the denial of a
statement now if you've been attentive
I'm sure you must have noticed this in
the negation statement can you guess
what it is
yes the negation of a statement is
denoted by adding tilde to the letter
with which the actual statement is
denoted if the actual statement is
denoted with P the negation would be
denoted by tilde P
and similarly if the actual statement is
denoted by our the negation would be
tilde R and so on now that we've
understood the relatively easier
examples let's take it one notch higher
consider this example all the vehicles
have four wheels what will be the
negation of this statement will it be no
vehicle has four wheels no that wouldn't
be correct because negating does not
imply writing the opposite so it could
be some vehicles have four wheels this
wouldn't be correct either
why remember we don't correct the
statement but just negate the statement
this is getting interesting can you give
it one more try how about all the
vehicles do not have four wheels here we
negating the sentence right
but even this cannot be the negation of
this statement confused let me explain
why here we're talking about a group
that is a group of vehicles and not a
particular vehicle or a single entity in
such cases there is a simple solution to
find the negation as a first step we
just add the phrase it's not the case or
it's false that to the start of the
statement so in this case the statement
would be it's false that all the
vehicles have four wheels or it's not
the case that all the vehicles have four
wheels now we come to this second step
that is finding the negation of the
statement
can you tell me what these two
statements imply it means that there is
at least one vehicle which does not have
four wheels so the correct way of
writing the negation of such statements
is there exists at least one vehicle
which does not have four wheels this is
the negation of this statement
let's take one more example for better
understanding what will be the negation
of this statement here we are talking
about a group of numbers
hence the negation would be there exists
a number whose square is positive let me
give you a few more examples to work on
here they are what do you think the
negation of these statements would be
leave your answers below and in the next
video we'll see what compound statements
are
[Music]
you